I hate my life I need meaning purpose no
more pot I want to get high the other
way the real way I'm a combat pilot god
damnit along in the air and GTA's new
update this hippie outfit smells like a
Whole Foods bagger if I'm gonna be an
ace I gotta look like one time to drive
down to Oh lookie here my sabers back
Rockstar fixed the issue from the
hipster update where your car
disappeared if you downgraded to a
cheaper property thanks
oh you know Ben as I was saying mosey on
down to your nearby clothing outlet and
check out the fighter pilot suit holy Sh
fifty grand I can't commit to that my
pilot skills are rusty and I know from
experience not to dress like a poser
I'll take that rookie flight cap for my
first day at San Andreas flight school
I'll be back for that jumpsuit once my
parents see that diploma on the fridge
first day of school comes so nervous I
wonder if the other pilots will like Oh
shots fired too bad these idiots forgot
I know the back door hey-oh
so flight school brings you ten lessons
to tighten up that grip on your stick
landing a Titan in a thunderstorm may
seem easy until that engine blows out
we're touching down on a moving flatbed
might be fun until tunnel get high on
g-force with formation flying or let's
get low let's get fast in this
checkpoint race I enjoyed every one of
these and the pay was pretty solid
walked away with about 150 grand and you
can always replay them again for that
gold medal cash mom dad I did it time to
get a flight suit that looks good I'm
missing a chute though
well Amy nation's got the stuff six new
shoots for you and show your patriotism
with 25 new flag bags even snag a
secondary chute just in case Oh
oh yeah it's time to buy me a Joe c4 huh
well not today pal passive mode do it I
dare you to do it
three new air vehicles in a classic
Corvette hit the market a four-seater
Swift heli 16 Cedar Mill jet and then
there's the besra jet Don your mind
this weather is an ideal for my first
flight but whatever I can fly I'm pilot
oh haters on my six take them out mall
cop yep oh boy yes yes here we go punch
it one more time okay here well what a
mini good una mas Oh cops are on me yeah
Ezra is the cheapest of the three and
you'll probably have to grind some more
jobs to buy the others you'll be happy
to hear that this update has increased
the overall RP and cash earned from jobs
facing them more on difficulty in time
spent and there are plenty of flying
jobs to show off your newly earned wings
acquire targets pits a free-for-all mode
downtown where you hold on to a target
for 20 seconds to score points leave
through skyscrapers to shake them bogeys
there's G rating hot another versus mode
where you rush to capture the most flags
spread across the canyon air force zero
is a weird one with the task of
delivering a prototype jet across San
Andreas only there's a team defending
you and a team attacking you you got
tons of air races through the tight turn
downtown area or one out in the canyon
plus a handful of parachute jobs that
get creative with the reserve chute and
then there's a new flying capture match
called crowded airspace and it gets real
hectic once you find yourself rushing to
capture cases through windmills and
trust me there's nothing more rewarding
than crashing into a dude with the case
grabbing it and booking it back for a
score for instance this guy he thinks
he's home free not on my watch look
alive catch shot snag it back to the
chopper
ha ha later
oh yeah
but man this Swift helicopter is awesome
it's got side lights and retractable
landing gear how dope is that the flight
school update brings plenty to the table
and if you're looking to make some extra
cash for one of these new vehicles play
this weekend for the San Andres flight
school is then weekend abuse that double
RP and GT a doe August 22nd to the 24th
I'll see you in the skies babe